[Music]
I'm Desmond Wang my company is the
gentle gross we started about three
years ago the game I'm working on is
called cat quest which is an open-world
RPG after the first bootcamp coming back
two months later I personally have
become a better producer the mentors
generally helped us mall with
monetization methods how else we could
make more revenue out of the game like
putting in in-app purchases or maybe
DLCs
pricing models like maybe certain prices
would work better in other places
learning from the mistakes they made the
lesson that we share was all extremely
amazing game design man is tough right
but keep at it and you're going to get
there someday
do not ever give on your dreams
you